eastern poland where foreign forces have
come and gone for centuries
once again the streets of shemeshla echo
this time to the sounds of american
boots sightseeing but still a visible
presence
to reaffirm america's commitment to its
allies
in warsaw u.s vice president kamala
harris confirmed the delivery of u.s
patriot missile defense systems to
poland
i am here standing here on the eastern
flank
of nato
to reaffirm our commitment the united
states commitment to poland
and our nato allies
and there is no question that we stand
united
as it relates to many issues and the
particulars should ukraine
economic sanctions remain the main us
weapon for isolating moscow and exacting
a high financial price for the russian
invasion of ukraine
but as long as russia controls the skies
ukrainians pay with their lives
[Music]
one volunteer sent the u.s vice
president this message from the front uh
what can i say to mrs kamala harris
i would say that the necessary condition
to preserve global democracy is closing
this guide to russian aircraft
if you do this there will be victory for
democracy all over the world
for now the u.s focus is on drawing a
red line at poland
the number of american troops in the
country is in the thousands levels not
seen since world war ii
now this part of eastern poland is under
a high security alert so we can't get
out and film like we normally could but
the profile of this airport has become
distinctly more military in recent weeks
far more military aircraft taking off
and landing and far more military
hardware on the ground
the closest runway to the border with
ukraine is at jeshav airport there is no
mistaking the american presence here
once again in europe
talk of armies alliances war
19th century battle lines being drawn
with 21st century weapons
zane basravi al-jazeera jeshov eastern
poland